STEPHANIE WONG: If you're
new to Google Cloud,
there is a lot to
absorb especially
if you're excited to get
started in any of the many tools
out there, like big data
Analytics, Kubernetes,
Serverless, or machine learning.
I'm here to break it all
down so you can start
building things up right away.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So first things first,
cloud.google.com
is your starting point.
This is where you
will find information
about our products and offers.
If you want to
jump right in, you
can go directly to the console
or search our documentation
for quickstarts, solutions,
reference architectures,
and browse code samples.
You'll also find our latest
offers listed like free trials.
Pricing is also detailed
there, including
Google's pricing
list, a detailed cost
calculator for every Google
Cloud product and service,
and information on the free tier
for every applicable product.
Cloud.google.com is also
the place to access support,
to read customer stories,
to find partners,
and to understand
how Google Cloud is
different from
other public clouds.
You'll also find helpful
getting started resources,
like quickstarts, trainings,
and certifications.
But, in my opinion, the
best way to really get
started is the
Google Cloud console.
This is where you'll probably
spend the most time exploring
and using the platform.
It's where you configure
billing accounts,
create and manage projects, and
manage all of your Google Cloud
resources, regardless of
their data center location.
Every product and every
service has its own section
in the console left-hand
menu with dashboards,
detailed configuration,
and settings.
You'll also find interactive
quickstart experiences
right from inside the console.
Take this example quickstart
for Compute Engine.
Right from here, it'll
show you exactly where
to go in the console
for each step.
And within minutes, you'll
be running a two-tier web
application running a
Python web server running
on Compute Engine.
The Cloud Console also
offers a marketplace
with ready-to-go software stacks
to accelerate development,
so you spend less
time installing
and more time developing.
This allows you to deploy
production-grade solutions
in a few clicks with a single
bill for all of your Google
Cloud and third-party costs.
And it also offers direct
access to partner support.
To make sure you set
up your employees
with the right permissions
to use different Google Cloud
Resources, Cloud Console
integrates Identity and Access
Management, or Cloud IAM,
and provides a unified view
into security policies across
your entire organization.
This is also where you
would manage quotas
across the platform.
Every product comes with
one or more usage limits
across the platform, so
you can prevent one team
from spending the entire
org's budget on a rogue query
or compute job.
You can also use our iOS
and Android mobile apps
to monitor and manage your
Google Cloud applications
on the go.
Lastly, you can contact
support or sign up
for support packages for both
development and production
phases right from the console.
Role-Based Support enables
configuration on a per user
basis.
And case management
is integrated
into the Cloud Console.
Premium support offers
additional support
and faster response times for
mission critical workloads.
If you'd like to know more
about the Google Cloud Console,
check out the links below.
While the console is
powerful and flexible,
you can do everything
from the command line.
For every action in the console,
there is a G Cloud equivalent.
G Cloud is your scriptable
and all mighty CLI,
and it comes with
the Google Cloud SDK.
You can do things
like create resources,
change configurations,
and grant authorization.
There are other
command line tools
for products like
BigQuery and GKE.
The G Cloud SDK and these
CLIs come preinstalled
in Cloud Shell.
Cloud Shell is a
shell environment
hosted on Google Cloud
for managing your projects
and resources.
It's accessible from
a simple web browser
and is powered by a
small virtual machine
with persistent disk space and
up-to-date software for all
of your development needs.
It even comes with a really
handy web code editor.
If you'd like to know more
about developer tools,
check out the links in
the description below.
Now before you can use
the Google Cloud Console,
you will need a Google account.
You can create a
new Google account
or use an existing one,
such as your Gmail account.
We recommend that you enable
billing for your project
and that you sign up
for our free trial.
But if you don't sign up for
the free trial or are unable to,
you can still benefit from
the generous always free tier.
Once logged into the
Google Cloud Console,
I recommend that you
check out the main menu
and in particular the
Getting Started section.
Check out the checklist
to complete common tasks
like creating a project,
finding products and APIs,
and adding your very
first resources.
Back on the Getting
Started page,
scroll down to the
section Put Google Cloud
to Work, and click on Browse
Interactive Tutorials.
This opens up a
panel with a list
of tutorials of your
product of choice
without leaving the console.
Finally, check out the
main categories of products
Google Cloud has to offer--
Compute, Storage, Networking,
Operations, Tools, Big Data,
and Artificial Intelligence.
As you progress through your
discovery of Google Cloud,
keep in mind these
key resources.
Documentation can be found
at cloud.google.com/docs,
in-depth architectural diagrams
and tutorials at /architecture,
code samples at /docs/samples,
support at /support,
training at /training,
and free code labs
at g.co/codelabs/cloud.
Google Cloud can be a little
overwhelming at first,
but with this guidance
I hope that you are now
confident that your best ideas
can come to life in the Cloud.
I'm excited to see
what you build,
and I look forward
to your feedback.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
and share.
This is Stephanie Wong.
I'll see you all next time.